so Chris that opener cash is king
that is dumb the paid off home mortgages
almost 30 years ago we wrote that and
have been doing it never more true today
we should change the and have a special
like like some real dramatic music and
go the coronavirus special edition of
the Dave Ramsey show but we're just not
that way around here so no you know you
know I don't have a pandemic no and we
don't panic and you know the reality is
is you know I'm awfully curious and
you're at some point today I want you to
tell me the story of how you came up
with that saying because as you hear it
right now as people are really waking up
and I think we are seeing an awakening
right now in the midst of this where
people are starting to go you know
something that old Dave he might have
been on to something there's some really
funny stuff people making fun of me out
there right now it's really really funny
but it's in front of you
yeah because it's like he was right all
along so he's he's gloating or he's
saying I told you so I'm not but it's
just it's still funny right it's you
know and unless you just don't have a
sense of humor which I do I mean even if
it's making fun of me it's funny I don't
care who you are but the there's tons of
it floating around because it is this
this is I don't know when a brand has
been as validated by an event as the
frenzy brand being validated by all this
and it's not that we're telling you I
told you so because crap man I mean
Chris has done stupid and I've done even
more stupid than he's done I've got a
PhD in to you and B we're never here to
shame you or condemn you
we will bust your chops if you're headed
towards stupid and bounded and term to
keep going that way you won't like us if
if you want to keep going that way and
want us to endorse your stupid because
we love you and we want you to win
that's right and so but but and you know
that you just keep driving off into the
land of stupid it when winning is not
happening over there so but it is it is
it's a wake-up call for some folks in
it's a validation yes others that have
been doing things like staying out of
debt building an emergency fund and
investing only for the long haul mm-hmm
and riding the wave riding the roller
coaster and and you know it's stuff
we've talked about so much that it's
like and inside this building is so
normalized that we don't even think
about it anymore yeah but if you who are
not thinking about it you are in a mess
right you really are it's a part of our
DNA
you know we not only hear it and teach
it but we live it and so the thing that
I love to see Dave has taken people on
my show the chris hogan show people
telling me you know all this craziness
going on I'm okay I'm breathing easy and
you know that's so contrast to what I
hear from outside the people that are
yet to come to us but I think we're
gonna have an opportunity to reach
people Dave on a way that is heart
connected and I've heard you tell that
you know people can walk change but when
you go through some stuff when you
finally get scraped up enough and you go
you know what this ain't working yep dr.
Phil woman how's it working for you yeah
it's not no it's not how does it house
that attitude how's that Yolo
mmm you know Ramsey you're just no fun
you're such a sixty-year you know you're
such a Boomer meme you know Ramsey
you're no fun Yolo baby and right now it
doesn't look like all that right now it
looks like the three little pigs with
the if you know the story with a little
pig in the brick house instead of the
one that was in the straw and the sticks
and the big bad Wolf's out there huffing
and puffing he does not have coronavirus
he's blowing stuff down
that's exactly hey you know Dave but I'm
not hearing about right now is any kind
of deck on airline miles I'm not hearing
about credit cards yeah no you're not
you know but you know why because all of
those programs the problem is is here in
the next about 15 to 16 days they're
gonna start calling you know what else
is kind of quiet I mean it's not
completely shut up but it's pretty quiet
is Rams you don't know what you're
talking about there is good debt and
right now it doesn't feel like it does
it no it's true but and we've been
telling people all along the only good
that's one that's not there is paid off
that's right and the borrower is slave
to the lender
by the way that's true of these stupid
SBA loans that they're putting out there
that they're promising forgiveness on
you do you really want the DMV of small
business to be your master I mean do you
really want that how dumb you know
you're just asking for crap in your life
Dave Ramsey those are grants they're not
grants there are loans with forgiveness
provisions that have more loopholes than
an IRS tax code it's unbelievable well
I'll tell people grants don't have
interest rates okay
they just don't grants don't have
payment terms that's exactly right
and so people don't fall for that please
don't fall for that the last thing you
need to do is add more pressure to your
already packed plate how would you like
for the government to be telling your
church how to operate Oh does that does
that not give you just a little bit of a
chill it should it really should I mean
think about who's in Congress it look it
looks like the island of misfit toys up
there you want those guys dictating how
your church operates you gave them a
took a loan from now wait a minute
churches aren't eligible for these loans
are no absolutely okay that I did not
know yeah and you talk about a dadgum
cesspool a danger right there that's the
problem that's a really bad idea boys
and girls now there is a provision that
is not alone and it's not an SBA and
that is you can put off paying your
payroll taxes you the portion that they
employer pays of the payroll taxes does
not have to be paid this year and
instead can be repaid over the next two
years we will be doing that here right
because we're conserving cash because
the more cash we can serve the more the
higher the probability no one loses
their job in Ramsey here in this
downturn and so we're doing everything
we can to preserve cash and it's working
so far but the men we got a thousand
employees can you imagine not paying the
payroll taxes this year what that'll do
to cash it's pretty substantial go and
so I really does that that and that's
not a loan that's not alone it's just
simply a delay in the payment that's
legal
and so I will do that here and I want
you guys that have small businesses to
take advantage of that and but but you
know a lot of this stuff it's popping up
his stuff you don't need and you know
the payday lenders have dadgum ads
running about how they're your friend
they were never your friend no I mean
that they're no more your friend than
stupid timeshare that's right I can't
think of anything worse than a dadgum
timeshare Twitter to walk like oh you
guys anything I'm gonna take all my
money on the market it's like the
dumbest possible series of things you
could do people need to be smart too
because the payday lenders now have
turned into revolving lending instead of
installment loans yeah people are it's
it's still dangerous and sneaky
I still eight hundred percent interest
that's right that's today absolutely so
here's the thing the things that were
smart before this are smart during it
and we'll be smart after it smart didn't
change common sense didn't change but
desperation starts to make stuff look
like it's okay and it's not okay yeah
we're gonna walk through it with you
today Chris Hogan right here on the Dave
Ramsey show